okay so we are back with Batman fighting
the anti-batman and this comic not only
has one of the most ridiculous moments
ever in the history of Batman but the
ending's insane so in the last video we
picked up with basically failsafe
crushing the entirety of the bat family
I mean just like crushing these guys
even Batman they never had a chance but
now Superman's on the scene right the
Man of Steel himself steps up here's a
funny thing about this Batman Muses to
himself and he says okay so most likely
what Clark is doing right now is
analyzing the Fail-Safe robot using his
x-ray vision but I've most likely built
lead into it because remember Batman's
own subconscious is the one that built
failsafe for the purpose of it being
designed in a way to where Batman
himself could not actually deactivate
Fail-Safe the failsafe pops up whenever
Batman willingly takes a life and that
appears to have been the case we know
it's not necessarily the case but it
looks like it was and so because
failsafe is designed to take out Batman
the secondary design of Fail-Safe was to
withstand the justice this week because
obviously if failsafe goes after Batman
what's happening is exactly what would
happen the Justice League would step in
because they would see it as a rogue
robot and so the result of this is that
Batman built lead into Fail-Safe so that
Superman's X-ray vision cannot see
through it it's a pretty genius maneuver
the funny thing about this is that
Batman even says if I've designed
Fail-Safe the way I think I have then
Superman needs to be worried about
himself and he does because as soon as
failsafe realizes Superman's not going
anywhere he dons a couple of green
Kryptonite daggers witches dope like it
looks amazing because he immediately
takes off and then Superman goes after
this guy only for failsafe to impale him
with the Kryptonite daggers Superman's
out of commission like that and it's one
of the genius things to know right
because the entire basis behind failsafe
is to neutralize the Justice League if
necessary green Kryptonite is the
easiest way to take out Superman now
it's not the only trick that failsafe
has up his sleeve and we'll see how he
deals with Superman again later on on
because the way he does it is super
unique and amazing but one of the other
things that happens is that like all of
her Queen steps in right the Green Arrow
now I mean let's be honest with
ourselves right what's green arrow going
to do the cool thing here is Martian
Manhunter shows up now here's the thing
that a lot of non-comic book readers
don't know about Martian Manhunter he's
more powerful than Superman and in fact
in Grant Morrison's JLA from 1998
there's a point in the comic when
Superman goes as far as to say Martian
Manhunter is more powerful than he is
he's the most powerful being on Earth
he's on a whole different level but even
he doesn't stand a chance against
Fail-Safe because remember the entire
basis behind the design of Fail-Safe is
rooted in Tower of Babel what was Tower
of Babel that was a story where Raz al
Ghul got a hold of the Batman protocols
a series of files that literally detail
how to neutralize the Justice League so
that's exactly what failsafe is designed
to do Martian Manhunter is taken out in
no uncertain terms Black Canary shows
back up again with Oliver Queen there
they're both taken out in no uncertain
terms so now it's just Batman and
Superman just laying there and it's
trying to figure out what to do with him
now fortunately Tim Drake Robin shows up
now Batman does manage to pull the
Kryptonite dagger out he kind of heals
up Superman a little bit or at least
patches him up to a degree but the
reality is the Green kryptonites in his
system so they have to get him out of
there and get him to the Fortress of
Solitude in order for Superman to heal
but the funny thing about this is that
when the the the quinjet right the
Justice League jet shows up here the
initial indication or the initial
attempt is to get both Batman and
Superman to a particular location so
they can both recuperate but Batman
comes to this realization that Fail-Safe
is truly after him everybody else is
collateral damage the only reason the
Justice League are just being taken
apart piece by piece is because they're
stepping in in defense of of Batman but
if that wasn't the case they wouldn't
have to worry about anything Bruce Wayne
coming to that realization leads him to
tell Tim Drake take Superman to The
Fortress of Solitude so he can
recuperate everything thing he needs to
be made whole will be there because we
need him I'm getting out of here Phil
says after me I will lead him away and
that's exactly what he does now the cool
thing here is that when the Justice
League goes back on the attack Fail-Safe
does not go directly after Batman
instead what it does is it goes to
Gotham City now in turn the Justice
League response this is this is one of
the smartest Maneuvers and I'm really
excited to see how you guys feel about
this the Justice League response right
but as this is going on remember Oracle
is Barbara Gordon Batwoman she's kind of
the eyes and ears right she sort of
helps to Galvanize and organize a team
feed them information different things
like that and what she realizes is that
the entirety of the Justice League
fighting Fail-Safe here is not arbitrary
and it's not random it's done for a very
particular purpose that this is quite
literally a kill box what happens is
that because of the nature of this one
segment of Gotham that Fail-Safe has
fire he has the ability to magnetize hot
girls Wings he can neutralize eyes Black
Canary relatively easily it minimizes
collateral damage but maximizes the
ability to overcome the Justice League
and that's it the Justice League is
taken out in like the blink of an eye
there's no one there's no one to stand
against this guy that's one of the
coolest things about Fail-Safe he's the
answer to the question what happens when
you have a Batman that has no compassion
and is totally unrestricted in terms of
what it's willing to do to achieve a
goal with maximum resolve it's nuts
right it's basically Batman taking out
the entirety of the Justice League and
so at that moment you do have Dick
Grayson that tries to step in but none
of it helps and so with Batman taking
off and literally jumping out of the
ship what he does is he goes to the only
Safe Haven he can possibly think of the
only place that failsafe will not
immediately think to look the oceans and
he arrives in Atlantis in the realm of
Aquaman now of course Aquaman and those
guys basically bring him back and they
restore him to health but the biggest
issue that you have to contend with now
is that Aquaman at least is part of his
stories are going is not true
traditionally the king of Atlantis he's
more of just kind of the guy that people
look to as more of a guy than anything
else more so than that in the time that
Batman's recovering what Aquaman says is
Gotham City has fallen the Fail-Safe now
has drones that traveled through the
city and look for anybody who's trying
to break in in order to free those
individuals who are still trapped here
right different superheroes or whatnot
or to try to find a way to defeat
Fail-Safe itself more so than that in
order to have eyes and ears everywhere
it's taken over Barbara Gordon with a
kind of computerized device and so now
she operates as his eyes and ears seeing
not only everything going on in the city
of Gotham but everything around the
world and literally he says the
Fail-Safe robot is still hunting you it
hunts you endlessly it keeps going on
tirelessly you're basically believed to
be dead by the remaining superhero
Community but until the Fail-Safe robot
destroys you it will continue to hunt
you seemingly forever and so what he
says is at the end of the day the
Fail-Safe robot taking over Gotham kinda
seems to be its main goal and that's
when Batman comes to the realization
that's really what the Fail-Safe robot's
doing targeting Gotham City because
that's Batman's home targeting Gotham
and then literally turning Gotham into
just kind of a cesspool right where
people just commit crimes left and right
allowing the city to succumb to its most
base and destructive desires Batman
cannot stay away for long because he
loves this city so much he will
inevitably try to come back and that's
what failsafe is banking on it's one of
the smartest Maneuvers right like if you
can't find the person you're trying to
kill then go after the things they care
about and make them come to you it's one
of the most genius military strategies
that you could really even think of and
so in the face of all of this there's a
few different things that we learn right
when Fail-Safe is asking Robert Gordon
for a kind of update on what's going on
Barbara Gordon says 78 of metahumans
with a connection to Batman have
attempted breaching Gotham and have been
rebuffed or captured 17 of the remaining
beings are currently caught in unrelated
skirmishes and that's when failsafe
starts to realize there's a member of
the Justice League who is missing no
one's heard anything from Aquaman he
hasn't responded he hasn't said anything
he's dead silent and that's when it
comes to the realization Batman has to
be with Aquaman Batman has to be down
there and so failsafe in turn responds
travels down to Atlantis manages to
capture Aquaman even like punching a
hole through him to the point where he
gets to his heart and then threatens to
kill Aquaman in front of all of his
leaders or at least all of his generals
and whatnot and in turn one of them
basically calls Aquaman out and just
says like Batman's over there right
literally I just rat Batman out now a
lot of it seems due more to disloyalty
than anything else and orem's just kind
of the guy who does that right you know
like he's just he's the dick of like the
Aquaman Mythos right like he's the
snitch right snitches get stitches so
it's one of those things where like once
this happens Batman amusing to himself
knew it was only a matter of time before
failsafe figured out where he was and
when he got down there he would by any
means necessary try to figure out
Batman's location even taking Aquaman
hostage and threatening to kill him in
front of all the atlanteans and so when
this happens once Fail-Safe gets to
where Batman is supposed to be Batman's
gone and he's basically teleported to
the Justice League headquarters on the
moon now the funny thing about this is
that he's basically planned for this
because you know it's Batman he always
plans but I love the way the chip
zadarski plays this out right yes
Batman's a planner and a schemer but the
bigger thing here is that Fail-Safe
knows everything Batman's going to do so
he's going to have to plan for the guy
that plans for everything that he plans
for it's nuts it's kind of wild and so
realizing that failsafe's armor is
basically impervious right it was
designed to be that way and even his
innards are impervious so like just
Conventional Weapons he ends up grabbing
a new genesis gun which is powerful
enough to punch a small hole in
failsafe's armor but not enough to
actually blow his body apart but he
wasn't really even planning on that
right he simply had a means like he was
achieving a particular goal he's playing
the long game here and so in this fight
between the two it's basically cat and
mouse it's Batman jumping from one part
of the Watchtower to the next trying to
outmaneuver Fail-Safe while failsafe is
basically taking out every single trap
that Batman sets up until Batman gets to
the teleporter and when failsafe had
expected this what it didn't expect was
for Batman to reverse the teleporter and
instead of it teleporting Batman away it
teleports failsafe back to Earth now
failsafe was able to get to the
Watchtower just by virtue of using a
vessel in the first place but with no
conventional means of interstellar
flight meaning no way to fly to the moon
the Fail-Safe is basically trapped on
Earth but the crazy thing here is that
Batman is also trapped in the Watchtower
because with The Watchtower basically
being blown to pieces now he starts
calling for these like emergency rafts
right something they can get him back to
Earth but they're all basically
destroyed he's stranded out there
floating through space with nothing but
an oxygen mask that's running out of air
floating towards Earth now this is when
you get to the most the most Batman
moment ever in the history of DC Comics
it's ridiculous I mean it's ridiculous
but amazing at the same time right it's
just it's one of those things right
because Batman always survives so what
he ends up doing here
as he makes his way he gets back to some
remnant of the vessel and finds that
like there's an oxygen tank there right
so not too weird that's kind of a normal
thing right Reserve oxygen tanks and so
on right so this thing gives them about
12 hours and 15 minutes of oxygen then
what he does is he hooks the tank up to
like just a piece of metal right just a
piece of this vessel and then starts
floating back to Earth but what he says
is that as he moves towards Earth he'll
be caught in the planet's gravitational
pull right that if he continues at this
speed he's just gonna be pancaked
pulverized by the Earth because remember
as the Joker taught us in Batman the
Animated Series it's not the fall that
kills you it's the sudden stop
and so because of this Batman comes up
with this ridiculous scheme of basically
using this device to effectively speed
up and slow down right so like slow his
momentum so he can fall to Earth
and he can hit the ground
and survive which he does
it's the most ridiculous thing that I
think I've ever seen in a Batman comic
and I love it I absolutely love it
right like this like even for a Batman
comic it's just outrageous but it's
awesome it's amazing so he makes it to
Earth and then just gets up he suffers
no ill effects from Landing from like
literally falling from the Moon to Earth
he just gets up not only that he arrived
where he wanted to be at the Fortress of
Solitude and so when that happens he
basically mixes his way in right when
Superman starts to wake up he's not
really a hundred percent but he's strong
enough to where he can kind of hold his
own to a degree and that's when Batman
tells him okay Fail-Safe is going to be
on his way here he'll be picking up on
the fact that I fell from the Moon and
survived and he'll surmise where I
landed and then he'll make his way here
he'll know exactly where I'm going and
he will show up on the doorstep of the
Fortress as well attitude so we
literally tells Superman I need you to
buy me some time now the funny thing
about this is Superman goes into this
with like battle armor and everything
expecting like some kind of a long drawn
out fight even preparing for the
Kryptonite daggers that failsafe has but
failsafe basically tells him I know
things about you that you don't even
know about yourself for example
kryptonians much like humans have
pressure points when he presses one of
them Superman's heat vision activates
without him wanting to and it reflects
off the glass on his visor and hits him
in the face and takes Superman out it's
amazing like I've never seen that happen
before and I was like dude that's dope
like making Superman use his own powers
against his will it's genius writing but
the other part of this is that Batman
tells Tim Drake he tells Robin I punched
a hole in failsay's armor the reality
here is that no conventional weapon that
we have on Earth even something like a
nuclear device would be enough to take
this guy out he was designed to be that
way but what I did do was punch a hole
small enough that we can actually put in
a nanotech virus because if we just put
a random virus in his body it would
immediately destroy it right it would
immediately fight it off because I would
have calculated for that I would have
prepared for that instead what we have
to do is introduce a virus that will
gradually change its programming and
gradually modify it but the question
that Tim Drake has is but what if it
doesn't work because this is the last
stand of the Alamo Batman there is
nobody else right so if this doesn't
work then we're both done with all our
living but Batman ever the planner tells
Tim Drake don't worry I have a backup
plan because I'm Batman after all Tim
Drake it is my comic book so the thing
that happens here is Batman you know
kind of being serious here Batman tells
him like failsafe was designed to fight
me he was not designed to fight Batman
and Robin now they both go into this
knowing there's no way they can overcome
Fail-Safe in a traditional sense with
the two of them just fighting they know
that right it's really more of a moral
boost but it's also just a great tribute
right watching like Batman and Robin
racing off into death but the cool thing
here is that in this fight that they
have Batman kind of comments and says
these this guy is not like some Thug or
some ex-felon this is me an unrestrained
version of me so we cannot fight this
guy in the traditional sense it's all
designed to be a distraction and that's
exactly what Batman does In This Moment
he plunges the virus into Fail-Safe but
it's not enough to take him out it's not
enough to take Fail-Safe out they have
by all standards the measurement failed
the programming doesn't quite work right
the programming looks like it's trying
to work but in the time when it takes
for this programming to function
literally failsafe says eliminate Batman
and that's it it didn't work at all and
so fail safe fires off a gun at Batman
and then seemingly Batman dies on the
spot right literally incinerated by
Fail-Safe now here's the thing I'm on
the fence as to whether or not I'm gonna
I want to tell you guys what happened
next
because
you know what let's do it let's do it
let's let's I I don't wanna I don't want
to leave you guys hanging I don't leave
you guys saying so what this looks like
here we don't get a definitive answer
here but what it looks like here this
gun uses the Omega sanction of dark side
and the reason why is because if you
guys remember from final crisis Batman
was hit with darkseid's Omega sanction
which normally would eradicate somebody
but because of the Batman comic he ends
up getting teleported through time this
seems to be similar because when it
looks like Batman is completely and
totally destroyed instead it's seemingly
he's just teleported somewhere else we
don't know where he is we have no idea
what happens or if he even remembers who
he is we have no idea what's going on
but we'll find out when we cover more of
the Batman comics with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace